bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour cet espace autochtones en direct un
spécial 8 mars donc un spécial journée
de la femme
et aujourd'hui nous allons nous
intéresser évidemment à la femme
autochtone une seule invitée aujourd'hui
véronique legault bonjourbonjour
enchanté et bien sûr ellis queen notre
habituel chroniqueuse et ligier de
regard sur l'article bonjour il y
chargeant bonne journée des femmes à
toutes les deux mais vous aussi merci et
à toutes les femmes évidemment qui nous
écoutent j'espère qu'elles sont
nombreuses et on va parler donc de
féminisme autochtone n'est ce pas il
faut en parler c'est important parce que
ça fait partie de la réalité des femmes
autochtones
alors avant de parler de féminisme
parlons de vous véronique qui est de
vous d'où venez vous donc en fait je
fais partie de la communauté un mohawk
de kahnawake
je suis présentement étudiante en
linguistique à la maîtrise à
l'université concordia
je m'intéresse beaucoup au sujet tout le
site enjeux qui touchent principalement
les femmes autochtones ou si la jeunesse
oui donc je suis vraiment content de
l'éducation aussi absolument un sujet
qui vous intéresse beaucoup
et les langues et particulièrement la
langue - la transmission poussé
parlons-en tout de suite c'est l'année
internationale des langues autochtones
et vous avez été invité à vous rendre à
l'unesco en janvier pour représenter les
autochtones du canada et les langues ne
naissent pas absolument d'enfants ont
représenté les jeunes autochtones du
canada
donc c'était vraiment une super belle
expérience que j'ai eus j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir comment se déroulait
les séances elle nesko donc comme un
clip décisions sont prises
il y avait toutes sortes de panels de
discussion très intéressant c'est là
qu'on se rend compte que tous les
activistes s des langues autochtones on
est tous un peu l'image de ce fait
intéressant de voir comment chacun
chacun est ce que vous avez eu
l'occasion de parler dans votre langue
pendant que vous étiez là non non
malheureusement on n'avait plus un
s'il ya une suite d'observateurs mais
par contre j'ai pu discuter avait après
l'essai en personne oui est ce que ce
sont les femmes qui vont sauver les
langues autochtones
moi je crois que oui j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir dans le poids des fans surtout
dans la revitalisation linguistique je
pense que ça passe surtout par les
femmes je peux parler de ma communauté
ce que j'ai su en faire cadeau à qui on
a beaucoup vu des différents exemples de
ça par exemple l'école diwan euros qui a
été fondée dans les années 70 80
je me trompe par un groupe de mères qui
était insatisfaite un peu du côté
culturel d'enseignement culturelle et de
la langue dans les autres s'étant
scolaires de la communauté donc ensemble
ils ont décidé de fonder leurs propres
écoles puis d'enseignés humain donc
sachez aussi un modèle super inspirant
encore un exemple peut-être un peu plus
fait sens et le language in est donc ça
c'est un organisme qui est fortement
inspiré du modèle maori en nouvelle
zélande oui donc c'est un plat serait ce
que dans le fond les parents peuvent
amener leurs enfants d'âge préscolaire
pour ce faire pour être un peu
l'immersion dans la langue donc parce
que souvent on voit des situations parce
que les parents ne peuvent pas
nécessairement eux-mêmes transmettre la
langue
oui donc ils peuvent emmener leurs
enfants loeb s'est vraiment bien c'est
encore une fois une initiative des
femmes kanawaki longue démarche qui
voulait inscrire ce à l'autre parent de
la communauté d'accord alors sur
facebook je sais pas si jean françois a
commencé notre et 10 m mais
jean-françois va lancer un sondage
maison là je vais vous poser à vous
aussi la question quels enjeux touchant
les femmes autochtones devraient être la
priorité des gouvernements et des
organismes selon vous il ya quatre choix
mais je vois une chose pour l'instant
elle vous salissez son choix en fait
c'est sur l'enjeu le plus important
selon moi ça serait la sécurité la
sécurité la santé
donc je pense que c'est la base de toute
chose pour que les femmes puissent
s'épanouir faut qu'au moins qu'elle a
besoin
oui absolument les choix que jean
françois a indiqué mais on peut retenir
ces deux là aussi la violence dont
contrôles de sécurité
ça touche la violence l'éducation
l'emploi et bien sûr les droits des
femmes autochtones aux quatre enjeux
primordiaux finalement pour la vie des
femmes est ce que vous êtes une
féministe véronique oui je pense que je
peux m'associer à ce terme
c'est sûr je suis moi je fais une
distinction avec contre les féministes
jeunes féministes mais général puis le
féminisme autochtone je pense que des
distinctions à ses fondamentaux qui sont
selon moi le féminisme autochtone il y
prend source avec les mouvements de
décolonisation donc cédé en jeu un peu
différent c'est surtout je pense dans la
façon la façon de mener les luttes qui
sont différents fondamentalement
justement il faut des colonisés l'image
de la femme autochtone l'école dé
colonialisent est aussi l à la relation
justement la façon qu'ont interagir avec
les femmes autochtones donc l'état tous
les services ou s'il est à la société en
général
ben justement de coloniser la façon des
services pour ce que vous venez de la
santé et la violence l'éducation l'accès
à l'employabilité
en fait avec la colonisation est venue
la loi sur les animaux et avec la loi
sur les indiens est venu le retrait de
pratiquement tous les droits des femmes
soutenons absolument absolument qui je
pense que justement la loi sur les
indiens c'est cela que celles accumulées
c'est la calcul mais justement les
politiques
la simulation et la loi sur les indiens
c'est fondamentalement sexistes ou s'ils
s'avisent les droits des femmes
autochtones oui évidemment il ya une
autre difficulté et ça vous l'avez vécu
vous personnellement puisque vous êtes
par votre mère mohacs elle est donc vous
l'avez dit originaire du ghana wagué et
par votre père québécois donc quand
votre mère a épousé votre père ou enfin
est devenue sa conjointe elle même a dû
quitter la communauté et ça c'est c'est
aussi des répercussions que les femmes
autochtones on va vivre dans certaines
communes à est absolument puis aussi
saluer une répercussion sur la culture
aussi parce que j'ai pas eu le même
accès à la culture
en terme de longues pizza que j'aurais
pu avoir si j'avais eu le droit de
rester sur la communauté
donc c'est effectivement des enjeux
c'est vrai que les réalités sont
différentes aussi d'une communauté à
l'autre on n'a pas les mêmes règlements
au sein de la communauté
mais dans votre cas ça a été primordiale
et c'est pour ça que vous voulez
d'ailleurs vous replonger dans dans vos
traditions dans votre langue dans vos
origines finalement absolument dispense
c'est un peu comme ça que je vis mon
féminisme c'est en mairie appropriant
les rôles traditionnels féminins de ma
culture
donc j'espère beaucoup à apprendre la
langue pour pouvoir la transmettre à mes
enfants parce que j'ai l'impression que
c'est un devoir que j'ai eue de l'ufal
oui ça a pas l'air facile
non sans dire ça c'est jamais évident
mais je pense que ça vaut vraiment oui
avec vos amis et s'ils partagent le même
espoir de continuer la langue et puis
transmettre cela me met absolument sujet
la chance de devenir d'une communauté
parce que les efforts l'instit sont
vraiment plus à partager
absolument pas j'ai beaucoup d'amis des
jeunes mères qui retourne sur les bancs
d'école pour apprendre la langue en a
beaucoup qui ont fait le court il court
immersif de deux ans sur ma communauté
puis il y en a beaucoup qui vont suivre
ça pour justement les transmettre à
leurs enfants il y en a beaucoup qui
deviennent des enseignants de la langue
aussi dans votre qu'est-ce que vous êtes
très avancé dans l'apprentissage de je
pense que mon corps mon background en
mes études universitaires en
linguistique m'ont beaucoup aidé je me
considère pas influencé nécessairement
mais j'ai un très bon niveau en lecture
en écriture
mais c'est sûr comme on parlait un peu
les ordures font en sorte que j'ai de la
difficulté à le pratiquer parce que
c'est pas partout qu'on peut mais le
buteur non non non non non non non c'est
quand même encore assez difficile d'une
part contre le maroc n'est pas une
langue en danger mais je pense que oui
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de
locuteurs langue maternelle
si je ne me trompe pas c'est environ 400
locuteurs de langue maternelle par
contre est vraiment très peu de langue
seconde
si on compare avec d'autres langues
qu'amélie nous où les cris sont des
langues un petit peu plus par les lignes
petit poucet que eux y ont peut-être un
peu moins vite eu de prix de
transmission entre générations
mais oui je pensais encore mais moi je
très optimiste je pense que la
revitalisation et bien et bien entamée
puis alors on va se tourner des
richesses que vous connaissez les
artistes inuit beaucoup à vous en t3
elles font partie de la même famille en
plus donc artistes de générations en
générations
et en fait si elles sont par audel parce
qu'aucune des trois n'est vivante mais
si on part des c'est parce qu'une grosse
exposition qui leur est consacrée
hellich depuis déjà un certain temps
du côté des états unis oui c'est
vraiment remarquable juste l'évolution
de cette exposition
ça s'appelle à court de tennis et qu'il
n'y avait ni pour tracer un portrait
familial de kinect et fritz et leur
village oui c'est le nom qu'ils donnent
au canada
ou comme cette berceau de l'art inuit au
canada mais le nom in us et kenya est
alors celle a donné qu'ils ont pu pour
l'exposition
mais c'était le musée à saintes fait au
nouveau mexique qui eut l'idée de
demander cette exposition là on voit les
pavés visée doit aller on voit la gauche
s'est petit à l'occassion à la patrie
pour des gogos sentent et puis annie
proulx gauche à doite et toutes ces
trois artistes étaient vraiment les
vedettes dans la nuite de leur époque et
ils sont toutes les mêmes familles ça
c'est une image de piriac et shona et
elle était très connue pour ses oeuvres
qui montrait des femmes inuites et les
légendes
c'est l'ancêtre sas et wissous c'est le
première est petit ou la question elle
fait partie de la première regroupe des
artistes de le fameux programme de
gréver décrypteurs louis alors l es12
les vedettes qui est sorti de cette
première génération d art inuit l'heure
on passe à paris prouve que sa fille et
elle avec le cfc images il est choisi de
montrer un petit peu qu'est ce qu'on
voit à clips de recettes
l'arrivée des technologies de sud ici on
voit ça c'est une bête tôt c'est une
vraie histoire bateau de lever du sein
qui essayent de rentrer à équilibrer
recettes dans 1947
c'était plus sain et sauf c'était puis
le 2 mois qui s'est cassé en deux le
bateau s'est cassé en deux nuits une
tempête a pris de marine allemands sont
pas cheap ou look était connu pour
montrer un peu c'était quoi la vie
équipe de sète au milieu du xxème siècle
et puis dernier mon arrivée à annie pour
tout geek et annie pourre du coup qu'il
faut dire les pins juste une vedette de
la réunion est elle est une vedette de
l'art canadienne contemporain et avec
elle elle est connue pour ses images de
tous les jours les scènes domestique et
ce qu'il a vraiment démarqué c'est aussi
élaboré pour la première fois comme ça
les images aussi qu'on peut dire
difficile la violence conjugale elle
peut ou peur de montrer un peu les côtes
est difficile de l'évolution de la vie
dans l'arctique la sexualité aussi
aucune retenue
non aucune retenue de tous et puis elle
était en 2006 elle a reçu le subit ward
qui est un oiseau canada qui est donné
un artiste moins de 40 ans qui est
démarqué l'archonte appellerait canada
alors mais pour le première fois
l'exposition a connu tony ils ont mis
toutes ces trois artistes ensemble parce
que souvent les gens savaient même pas
qu'ils étaient reliés dans la même
famille et c'était conçu pour et c'était
en 2016 c'est des consuls juste pour une
exposition
mais cette comédienne monde de grands
succès au nouveau mexique qui maintenant
c'est devenu une exposition itinérante
aux états unis et c'était même à new
york au smithsonian les critiques et les
revues qui est écrit le new york times
the times et ce c'est juste très
intéressant de voir ces trois artistes
canadiennes et muette dont hausse des
états unis et la public et à raisonner
avec le public quand c'était pas
possible donc depuis 2016 alors à me
promener
est ce que c'est une exposition qui va
continuer de circuler aux états unis
oui un pur de la dernière exposition
c'était à pasadena en californie et sa
famille en décembre
il ya les nouvelles dates qui va être
annoncé pour 2019 ça va être un problème
le prochaine mais les dates on va savoir
les dates ici printemps et puis d'autres
dates qui suivront d'accord y'a pas
encore les dates prévues pour les
canadairs d'hommes et de femmes qui il
comme un peu le lait le commercial de le
programme il en doute le succès de ce
qui se passe aux etats unis c'est ce que
veut que ça vient du canadien jouait
mais il en train de développer une suite
à cette exposition qui vraiment
mettrions vais peut-être les oeuvres de
les artistes inuit qui creva maintenant
alors il y en a comme les trois vedettes
qu'on a vu dans cette exposition
mais il fait vraiment suite pouvoir et
regarde ces femmes est hâté le terrain
et puis maintenant c'est ça qu'on a
maintenant elle
mais dénoncer plein d'autres femmes
aussi par la suite complètement les
sujets c'est très difficile de comme
trop parler de l'influencé ni même la
wii est ce que ça pourrait partir en
europe aussi par exemple parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'intérêts également de l'art
inuit en europe mais c'est important que
vous avez soulevé ça parce qu'il
égalerait de la rue newton airways j'ai
pas de l'information oui je pense que
tout le monde regarde cela de près et il
faut juste souligner parce que on s'est
posé des questions les gens qui qui a vu
l'exposition qui était d'organiser comme
pourquoi ça résonnait oui pourquoi pas
résolu ni pourquoi tant d'intérêt oui
parce que c'était avec le public le
grand public ni et ils ont dit que c'est
d'abord dans le milieu de l'art c'est
très rare d'avoir les expositions
organisées autour de l' influence d'une
femme artiste un autre femme artiste
second s'est fait en relation avec les
hommes
oui ici encore moins rare d'avoir encore
plus encore plus rare d'avoir une femme
autochtone est d'abord une exposition
comment les femmes autochtones à
influencer d'autres artistes femmes
autochtones alors c'est quelque chose de
vraiment unique
et aussi on voit aussi c'est un regard
féminin sur l'évolution de la société à
qui le dorset et l'évolution de la
société dans l'arctique et c'est très
rare sur le plan culturel même si dans
le sud
alors c'est comme il ya beaucoup de
choses et rennes unique et envoie on
parle des fois comme les les choses que
les autres ou de femmes s'y niche mais
on voit comme avec cette résolution par
exemple que c'est pas ça ça résonne avec
tout le monde oui absolument
annie n'a pas eu d'enfants donc il y
aura pas une quatrième génération calice
des enfants mais je sais pas s'ils
viendront d
[Rires]
on va surveiller mais on va surtout
surveiller l'arrivée de cette expo on
aimerait évidemment beaucoup qu'elle
vienne jusqu'au canada
oui il pour les gens qui s'en posent
états unis et le cas présentement et
pour aller seul et le site web du dorset
finers à mieux les hyènes et puis à
l'exception
non j'ai enfin la soirée aura sûrement
la formation il va pouvoir de mettre sur
la page facebook pour qu'on puisse aller
aller voir les oeuvres de ces femmes là
qui sont incroyables est-ce que vous
avez véronique des artistes autochtones
que vous suivez beaucoup des femmes
artistes qui dont le travail vous
intéresse mais refuse une de mes tantes
qui fait beaucoup de penseurs du j'adore
donc toutes sont approchés alors puisse
expliquer ce qu'elle représente dans son
ensemble et visant juste autochtone
justement elle commence en drop cas
sandra picard
vous pouvez sûrement trouvé sur internet
sur facebook
ok sinon est-ce que vous avez bon parce
que on le voit les femmes autochtones
heureusement d'ailleurs prennent de plus
en plus de place dans la société
on les voit à divers échelons il
faudrait les voir encore plus présente
c'est bon parce qu'il ya encore un
manque là comme dans la société en
général pour les femmes mais est ce
qu'il ya des modèles féminins que vous
observez que vous suivez oui mais en
fait tout ma famille pour moi sont des
modèles d'exempter exemplaire de
résilience est féminin puis si je trouve
c'est suffisant pour moi et pour
justement mecs privée nommée project
alors les projets que vous avez à suivre
la prochaine fois ça va être quoi
bonne question je vais commencer par
terminer mon diplôme et ouais je sais
pas si jean françois des réponses à son
sondage vais vous rappeler la question
parce qu'elle est vraiment intéressante
quels enjeux touchant les femmes
autochtones devraient être la priorité
des gouvernements et les organismes
selon vous la violence l'éducation
l'emploi et les droits des femmes
autochtones ça c'est les droits c'est
primordial je pense que c'est à la base
de tout combien tu dit jean-françois 53%
la violence on le voit parce
qu'évidemment il ya eu deux grandes
enquêtes qui ont touché justement cet
enjeu particulier la violence et c'est
vrai que les femmes sont les premières
concernées et c'est une réalité qui les
touchent
on s'imagine toujours que la violence
c'est oui peut-être mais en réalité à
chaque fois qu'il ya des gros sujets sur
les femmes ça touche encore le domaine
de la violence
ça démontre le travail qui reste à faire
aussi dans justement pour les droits des
femmes autochtones parce qu'on se bat
depuis les années 70 dans le même temps
mais dans les mêmes temps dieu
concernant la violence oui oui et les
droits par contre j'y reviens parce que
évidemment à la base si les femmes
avaient les droits qui leur qui devrait
leur revenir
j'imagine que ça changerait la donne
pour le reste aussi ça viendrait toucher
l'éducation l'emploi
quand vous pensez aux droits lesquels à
votre avis ce sont ceux qu'on doit
récupérer avant tout moi c'est celui
d'une communauté moi qui vois ce que les
femmes ont beaucoup d'importance dans la
vie politique
donc moi je crois que ça commence ça
commence là par la réappropriation des
droits politiques et communautaires puis
aussi moi je suis une fervente défend
défenseurs de l'idée que la culture
notre île tropicale
la population de nous qu'une seule va
vraiment changer puis des faits établir
une certaine balance dans nos
communautés
avant l'arrivée des colonisateurs est-ce
que chez les mots ac on était on vivait
dans une société matriarcale où
patriarcal de matriarcat ouais donc en
fait où elle d'entités passe par la
femme
contrairement à la donation est ce que
c'est l'homme puis aussi il ya un rôle
très important de la femme dans la vie
communautaire dans les décisions
politiques sont les femmes avaient le
droit comme un droit de veto serait les
chefs qui quittait élus oui puisqu'elle
est ici ça fait du sens parce que les
femmes sont celles qui s'occupait des
enfants qui pouvaient voir comme quel
enfant oui quel tel leadership
mais ce qu'il y avait des femmes cheffes
mon sens une bonne question je peux
répondre je n'ai pas assez
je pense de plus les hommes qui était
chef mais qui avait toujours les femmes
en arrière dit oui quel est le pouvoir
même de lewy ok alors avec l'arrivée de
la colonisation tout ça est une balayé
du revers de la main
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il serait possible
de reconstruire une société matriarcale
chez les mots à vous pensez comme dans
notre communauté on est toujours là face
à face la destruction très
traditionnaliste qui pensent justement
auront défendu malgache les clans pitts
appuyer le système de bandes qui sont
imposées par le gouvernement
oui c'est toujours une question assez de
cela répond ou et voir si est ce
possible de concilier les deux c'est
encore une question concernant
absolument écouter on va terminer ce
facebook live sur cette dernière réponse
avant de vous quitter qu'est-ce que vous
souhaiter pour les femmes dans l'avenir
pour les femmes autochtones évidemment
en fait souhaite que tous les femmes
autochtones puissent vivre en sécurité
puissent vivre leur culture vivent leur
longue transmettre ce qu'elles veulent
puis d'accomplir ce qu'est ce qu'elles
veulent fois les chefs vous aviez un
dernier mot à ajouter avant qu'on se
quitte
non mais je veux juste revenir là dessus
c'est vraiment de voir lors des femmes
soit la musique les écrivains et parce
que parce qu'on voit la culture envoie
une réalité mais c'est pas meetic et à
travers les choses de succès comme eux
qui s'exprime directement aux lecteurs
et auteurs d'ailleurs j'en profite pour
le dire sur le site des espaces
autochtone on a beaucoup de portraits
déjà on a eu 1 4 portraits de femmes là
deux femmes féministes qui s'expriment
sur ce qu'est le féminisme autochtone en
alors ça c'est un des articles à lire
il ya aussi ce portrait de joséphine
bacon la poète innu
une femme extraordinaire une femme
d'exception et puis donc tout au long du
site si vous défiler dans le site d'
espace autochtone vous allez voir
également d'autres articles qui portent
sur les femmes sur la réalité des femmes
en 2019 alors je vous invite à les
consulter
merci à toutes les deux merci ne fut pas
très bientôt et avoue évidemment à la
semaine prochaine pour un autre facebook
la rive au revoir
[Musique]